it's happening
ah it's happening it's oh my god so we
were watching the zero barrows
livestream Henry can't lies it was still
playing on my phone right now Henry
Cavill came on and they were doing this
great Q&A and they're like can you show
it and and Jackson iron table this is
literally it just happened seconds ago
but it's official
it's finally happening I'm excited
it's right here on the poster it says
HBO max 2021 this was a big deal I think
for it to get Henry Cavill involved
become I got him just so I'm so
overwhelmed because I've been watching
this for the last three hours I didn't
watch a long with Man of Steel but I was
listening to the commentary the whole
time that Harry Cowell came on I was
like oh snap
because Henry Cavill did an interview
not long ago where he seemed like he was
just wanting to move past this he was
one of the cast members who didn't seem
like he was in full support of it but
then to come out here it was like oh my
god Henry Cavill is showing his support
and then he made his crack about the
mustache it's officially happening age I
mean look as much as I'd love to do like
the most constructive breakdown of this
uh like the second it happened I was
like he did this thing where he like
bent over and shared I was like what was
in the reflection
what was that John I couldn't tell what
was in the reflection dude and then sure
enough it's actually happening oh my god
yes looks I'm excited 2020 one's a long
time away but looks like they finally
got the funding they gotta do the
additional reshoots cuz it is great that
he got like some hardcore fans involved
on this and actually the commentary I
thought was great on man to steal it
made me appreciate the movie that much
more John anything holy [ __ ]
now is I'm just really fascinated to see
what format they're gonna put this out
in I know there's a lot of speculation
that they want to do it hateful eight
style and like divided into chapters and
release it that way and I think that
that could be a smart idea if they want
to get the ball rolling while they're
finishing it or something like that yeah
like an actual TV show but I mean yeah
this news is gonna break the world I
mean I don't know what this means for
the DCE you because it seems like
Warner's has committed to not this
vision but at the same time he did
hashtag pause not stopped on his
original vero post which is certainly a
hit there's gonna be more zack snyder in
the DCU so I mean yeah it's it's the
friggin news man oh my god the news we
got okay whole probably talking about
that Ruby Rose thing later on and maybe
a little bit more on death release the
Ruby Rose but my heart just started like
going all right guys subscribe to the
real rejects this is uh badass yes it's
happening thank you guys